I just want to start with uh how like
everyone else how much I love the first
season and the episodes and I just want
to thank you for your hard work and
pulling this whole thing off for me as a
as a fan and for so many fans we were
dying waiting for the for the renewal
what was it like for the two of you
waiting to hear something long long yeah
because you know we
um
that there's uh you know you don't know
there's two different worlds right
there's the fans who received us so well
and were so excited and then there's
like the side of it that you you're kind
of waiting to see what what the other
side you know the business side and how
that works so for us we were just like
we're so excited for me I would say that
the show was received so well it felt
like we almost like we almost owed it to
our audiences to bring them more because
as as you know there's so much to the
Sandman so there's so much more to
explore yeah exactly yeah um I on
Twitter today when I mentioned I was
going to be talking to the two of you
um the thing that kept on getting
brought up was uh death the High Cost of
Living
um and anyway I'm just curious if you
have people have have people come up and
you know what I mean yeah people ask
about it they have I have no idea where
the stories go we have no idea
but I feel like what whatever we do you
know it's the same team it's Neil it's
Alan like we're we're gonna have solid
stories we're gonna explore these
characters more
so one of the things when I got the
press release about the the renewal was
it wasn't called season two it was the
Continuing Story of the Sandman or
something like that were you aware of
that that they're not calling it season
two
because I think
I think that's a unique
thing anyway Sandman so to call it
season two I think kind of it's that's
not what it is because they were just
more stories to tell and I mean as Kirby
said we don't we literally don't know
how this is going to be but it's it's so
new
on it I think because you know I think
part of the the hesitance really to call
it season two is that you know one of
the things about salmon and one of the
things you know about Neil is Neil loves
his fans and I think what there is the
understanding that we told some of the
stories and there's more to tell so it's
there's there's much more to it and if
you are a fan of the comic books you
know how many stories it's just that
once you put that into a TV format it's
it's broken up quite linear really it's
gonna be you know when you look at the
whole thing much like the comics it's
it's we're having these collections that
we that we put together listen you can
call it whatever they want I'm watching
so one of the things that really
surprised me today was you showed a
deleted scene
um from your episode which was I mean
obviously like again that episode is so
fantastic but that scene is so beautiful
and great and it kills me that it's only
going to be seen in this room can you
sort of for people that weren't in the
room can you sort of talk about what the
what that scene was and um what it meant
to you yeah so the scene that that was
shown here that was deleted which by the
way I had kind of forgotten about
because it was such a long time ago so
for me to see it
felt brand new again but it was a scene
where it's a continuation of of myself
and dream walking and talking through
London and you know he's going about
he's with me on a day of work right he's
like you know bring your kid to work day
um and um in that scene what we talk
about is you know death goes through her
job and and she expects what she does
obviously get resistance and so what she
talks about is she decided to experience
what she does so she lived for a day and
then met herself you know she was she
was taking it she she had her amount of
time and um
I think that uh that scene or that that
part that we're taking from the comic is
so key to who death is in the reason why
she's so compassionate is because she
understands because she went through it
so she understands that no one is ready
at the end because she herself being
deaf and knowing what was going to
happen still didn't feel ready to go
it's about a fantastic scene I I really
do hope that Neil and people reconsider
um so I know how Hollywood works and
with uh actors and with scheduling and
whatnot I'm just curious has anyone
asked you to save any dates in 2023
because maybe that would let me know
when you might be filming so I thought
that we don't know we have no one time
honestly we don't know we've just had a
conversation that you know there are
going to be more stories and that's all
we know so in a way because we're fans
as well if you can say that about your
own work but you know we're fans of Neil
we love you know we love this this is
such a beautiful project to be a part of
so we're kind of waiting and excited as
well just like everyone else because we
don't know so uh when we're going back
to work but I'm excited for it yeah
really sometimes this year you know I'm
excited to work with other people I mean
I loved working with Tom but it's like
it's going to be so exciting to have the
family and yeah and like and I hope you
will be there losing your family yeah
like moderating and just you know
keeping everyone calm yeah yeah I have
to wrap there I'm just going to say
sincerely how much I loved your work and
uh thank you for doing it and enjoy ccxp
thank you so you too